okay let's play e4 again oh it's a
french
oh i'm going to play the um what is this
called the ortho
nap ortho snap
gambit this is like a new thing
also inspired by the vampire chicken
jonathan trance um
did i mess up already i don't think i
messed up 95.
i'll admit i don't know too much here i
just know that looks
interesting and
yeah why not why not have some fun
bishop for his idea that's also an idea
okay
this is just a big mess
but yeah the idea with this opening is
to basically get an open position
against a french player like most french
players are used to close positions
and they're not used to being attacked
so so early
so brutally like this is already wow
that was
that was fast it was a 10 move game
the ortho schnapp gambit
uh yeah
i hope this serves as inspiration for
anyone wanting to learn this opening
this queen b3 very rare move
and like i did not know of this openings
existence until
maybe a couple weeks ago
people can check out jonathan trance on
youtube
um because he has at least a few videos
on this
but yeah the idea is you
basically provoke black to take and then
you get instant initiative
computer is not so fond of this but from
a human perspective
uh i think it's pretty fun we sight we
saw why it's fun
so is it youtube worthy twitch chat
you tell me should i put this on youtube
probably yeah i'll put this on youtube
the ortho snap
gambit
winning in 10 moves
youtube people say hi to the twitch chat
and like
and subscribe we have to get to 200 000
subscribers
i guess that's the next arbitrary goal